now a top South African judges ask
prosecutors to consider criminal charges
against the ANC government for ignoring
a high court order not to allow students
president to leave the country last week
Omar al-bashir
was attending an African Union summit in
Johannesburg when he slipped out of
South Africa before he could be arrested
he's wanted in The Hague on charges of
war crimes crimes against humanity and
genocide with regards to the Darfur
conflict well we spoke to two lasses
where Somali knee the senior political
correspondent for the ANC a TV news
channel in Johannesburg the judgment was
handed down last week when Omar Bashir
was here in South Africa and the High
Court had ruled that he cannot leave
South Africa until the matter regarding
South Africa's obligations to arrest him
in terms of the International Criminal
Court's founding statute their own
statute is concerned according to the
judge president of these cotton province
here in South Africa
Johnston Lambos there was completely
ignored by government the charge went on
to say that it's actually a threat to
South Africa's constitutional democracy
saying that democracy is underpinned by
the rule of law and if a government or
an agency of government or government
officials simply disregard court rulings
the judge saying that if the threats
that could erode the country's democracy
so it is a really significant judgement
in that sense because already
immediately after Omar al-bashir left
South Africa that debate immediately
started here in South Africa as to what
does it mean that government knew that
they were supposed to keep Omar
al-bashir in South Africa yet as far as
we understand he was escorted by the
South African Police Service from the
senton Convention Center where the AU
summit was taking place to watch off air
base a exit point that had been notified
of the court's ruling that he should not
leave South Africa yet he was able to do
so and actually assisted by state agents
so it's a very significant moment and
South Africans reflecting on the
meaning of all of this to the country's
constitutional democracy but at the same
time there's a new two-page about South
Africa's continued role within the
International Criminal Court the
governing part of the ANC coming out
strongly to say that the International
Criminal Court is no longer useful for
the purposes for which it was
established in fact the latest statement
from them says the government that they
lead should actually consider
temporarily suspending South Africa's
participation in the ICC now there's a
whole debate as to whether that's even
provided for in terms of their own Rome
stations but at the at the moment that
is the direction in which the government
of Jacob Zuma is leaning